LINES. I DON'T BELIEVE I'VE
EVER SPOKEN
TO THIS MAN. I OR INTERVIEWED
THIS MAN AND HE HOLDS A
POSITION IN MY OLD HOMETOWN.
THAT, SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT AND COUNTING ON
HIM TO RETURN
THE GREAT, BIG BLUE,
NEW YORK, GIANTS FRANCHISE
TO THE TOP OF THE PODIUM
AND HE IS THE NEW HEAD COACH
OF THE NEW YORK GIANTS
BRINED ABLE. HOW ARE YOU?
BRIAN?
BRIAN GOOD?
HOW ARE YOU? I'M GOOD FOR
HAVING ME ON. THANKS FOR
COMING ON
MY PLEASURE.I.
SO I
PROMISED MY AUDIENCE. I WOULD
START THIS WAY AND I WILL.
ALL RIGHT, YOU HAVE TO TURN
DANIEL JONES AND TO JOSH ALAN
GO
GO, YOU.
YEAH, YEAH.
HAVE. YEAH,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DO THAT.
RIGHT? WE'RE JUST GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
DANIEL. I THINK THAT'S UNFAIR
TO
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY I JUST
LEFT JOSH AND
HAVE COME IN HERE AND DANIEL'S
HIS OWN GUY.
JOSH HAS HIS OWN GUY. WE HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO. WE GO
IDENTIFY THE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO TO HELP DANIEL.
WHICH LOOK, THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS WE CAN DO, PARTICULARLY
ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE OF THE
BALL.
WE NEED TO BE BETTER AT. SO
IT'LL BE A LONG PROCESS BUT
EXCITED TO WORK WITH. THEN
OBVIOUSLY.
I'M I PLACE MY TONGUE FIRMLY
IN CHEEK
AND OUR FIRST QUESTION AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
I USUALLY DON'T DO THAT WITH
SOMEBODY WHO DID BUT I GUESS
IT'S
NOT. IT'S NO. IT'S
IT'S DEFINITELY, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE IN THE NEW YORK MARKET
AND I'M ASSUMING THAT YOU'VE
HEARD QUESTIONS
AND DIFFERENT WAYS TO ACTUALLY
SHAPE THAT. AND SO
WHAT, WHAT
DANIEL JONES HAVE THAT YOU CAN
BRING THE SYSTEM IN WHICH
JOSH, ALAN THRIVED AND,
AND GET HIM TO HAVE
RESULTS THAT ARE EXTREMELY
POSITIVE FOR THE GIANTS. WHAT
ABOUT THAT? DANIEL DID A GOOD
JOB
AS ROOKIE YEAR AND LOOK. HE'S
HAD SOME INJURIES AND AGAIN,
HE'S HAD SOME DIFFERENT PLAY
CALLERS AND DIFFERENT HEAD
COACHES AND
THAT'S THROUGH NO FAULT.
OUT OF HIS OWN. THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. IT
WAS, IT WAS
MANAGER, THE HEAD COACH, YOU
FROM HIS ROOKIE YEAR ALL THE R
WAY UNTIL THIS LAST
PAST SEASON. SO AGAIN, THERE'S
A LOT OF VARIABLES THAT GO IN
THAT AND IN TERMS OF HELPING
A PLAYER IMPROVE, YOU KNOW,
HERE IN THE SAME VOICE,
THE SAME SYSTEM,
SPEAKING THE SAME LANGUAGE.
THAT DANIEL HASN'T HAD YET. SO
WE GOT A LONG WAY TO GO WITH
HIM, BUT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PUT A
SOME TOGETHER THAT SUITS HIM,
YOU KNOW, HE'S A BIG STRONG
GUY
HAS SOME ATHLETIC ABILITY, BUT
WE'RE A WAYS OFF
FROM THAT, RIGHT? BRIAN TABLE
HERE ON THE RICH EISEN SHOW.
LET'S GET INTO
YOUR CAREER.
YOUR SO YOU WERE A GRADUATE.
ASSISTANT WAY BACK IN THE DAY.
WITH
NICK, SABAN AT MICHIGAN STATE.
HOW DID YOU FIRST WIND UP ON
HIS RADAR
SCREEN? WAY BACK IN THE DAY?
YES, AND A LOT OF LETTERS OUT,
YOU KNOW, COUPLE THEIR COACHES
GUY BY THE NAME OF CHRIS KOCH,
ENDED UP RETURNING MY CALL
BROUGHT ME IN FOR AN
INTERVIEW.
I LEFT, I WAS AT WILLIAM AND
MARY AT THAT TIME
WENT TO MICHIGAN STATE FOR
TWO YEARS WORK FOR NICK AND,
AND THAT STAFF. AND THEN
ENDED UP GOING TO THE NEW
WHEN ND PATRIOTS IN 2000,
COACH SABAN WENT DOWN TO LSU.
SO THAT WAS MY FIRST YEAR IN
THE NFL WAS 2000 WITH
WITH BILL
AND STARTED OUT ON
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE OF THE
YEAH, AND THERE WAS A CERTAIN
RETIREE THAT HAD JUST BEEN
DRAFTED CORRECT.
BRIAN BACK IN THAT DAY.
YEAH. YEAH,
YOU KNOW, I WAS AT MICHIGAN
STATE
AND HE WAS AT MICHIGAN.
MMM,
YOU KNOW,
WE'VE AND I JUST GOT A GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR TOM AND,
YOU KNOW, GET A REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM AND
HE'S JUST, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
THE BEST IT'S EVER PLAYED, BUT
ALSO
A GREAT HUMAN BEING
YOU KNOW, WE GO BACK AND
FORTH,
WERE ROUGHLY THE SAME AGE. I
WAS A
COUPLE
YEARS OLDER THAN HIM, BUT
YOU KNOW, SPARTY LAND AND HE
WAS OVER THERE AT THE OTHER
SCHOOL.
THANKS, RICH.
ALL RIGHT.
I REMEMBER WE STARTED OUT. WE
GOT FAST. THEY WENT DOWN AND
THEN THEY ENDED UP PUTTING
HANSON IN AND THEN BRING TOM
BACK IN AND TOM, ALMOST
LED HIM TO AN UNBELIEVABLE.
COMEBACK. VICTORY,
MUCH LIKE HE DID. I THINK IT
WAS AGAINST ALABAMA,
3835, OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IN THE ORANGE BOWL. I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. IT'S CORRECT AGAINST
ALABAMA WHO, YOU KNOW, YOU
EVENTUALLY
RETURN TO SAVING STAFF BACK
THEN
LATER ON IN YOUR CAREER
BRIAN DE BELM. AND IT WAS,
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THE FIRE
THAT BRADY GOT BUILT UP
IN HIM AT MICHIGAN IS
IS PART OF THE REASON.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE RINGS ON
FINGERS
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE AND ALSO
THE DEFENSE THE OFFENSE PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER
WITH BELICHICK.
IS THERE ANYTHING FROM THE E.
SABIN
YEARS, MICHIGAN, STATE,
ALABAMA, AND OBVIOUSLY
NEW ENGLAND THAT REST WITHIN
YOU. AND WHAT WHAT COULD THAT
BE? WHAT CAN GIANTS FANS
KNOW THAT COMES WITH YOUR
TWO OF THE ALL-TIME GREAT
COACHES AT THEIR LEVELS
AS WELL. YEAH, I COULD SPEND
I COULD SPEND ON
A LONG TIME.
TALKING ABOUT BOTH THOSE GUYS
IN THE INFLUENCE THEY HAD ON
DETAILED, XTREMELY
GREAT LEADERS, YOU KNOW,
UNDERSTAND HOW TO BUILD A TEAM
AND LEAD A TEAM
VERY, VERY SMART
IN TERMS OF SITUATIONAL
FOOTBALL CAN COACH ALL THE
BUT, YOU KNOW, AT THE END OF
THE DAY,
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK AND YOU
WATCH THOSE GUYS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE LEADERSHIP REALLY
STANDS OUT
AND OF HOW THEY
ORGANIZE, A TEAM
BUILD, A TEAM LEAD A TEAM
UNITED TEAM.
WEALTH AND WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
HEAR FROM BOTH OF THOSE GUYS.
WHAT ABOUT THE DEMANDING OF
OTHERS? WHAT ABOUT THAT? YOU
UM, YOU KNOW, NO I KNOW THAT
BUT THAT'S USUALLY,
HUH. THAT'S USUALLY SOMETIMES
AN ISSUE THOUGH, IS A NEW HC
COMES IN AND AND PUTS
IN A SYSTEM FROM
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY AND THEN
ADAM AND SOMETHING OF OTHERS
THAT
YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT'S DIFFICULT TO
COMMAND THAT RIGHT FROM THE
WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THAT?
THAT? AND THAT'S A GOOD POINT?
IT'S, YOU KNOW, TO ME, I'M
GOING TO COME IN AND BE
MYSELF.
I CAN LEARN FROM
A VARIETY OF PEOPLE WHICH I
HAVE. I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
ALMOST
TWENTY ONE YEARS IN THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE AND
HAVE WORKED FROM SOME VERY
GOOD PEOPLE
IN THE THINGS YOU LEARNED AS
THE YEARS GO BY IS
YOU JUST BETTER BE AUTHENTIC
AND BE YOURSELF. AND FOR ME,
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PLAYERS,
THE COACHES,
THE SUPPORT STAFF
AND EARNING THEIR TRUST
WITH WHO I AM. AND WHAT'S
AND THEN THE RESPECT COMES IN
AND WANTS TO RESPECT COMES IN.
THEN THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I'M GOING TO TRY TO DO.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE PERFECT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, I'M GOING TO
TRY TO BE MYSELF.
OF COURSE, YOU'RE GOING TO USE
LESSONS THAT YOU'VE LEARNED
ALONG THE WAY,
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE WHO YOU ARE.
WELL, I MEAN, AND IN TERMS OF
THAT
COACH BRYANT ABLE NEW HEAD,
COACH IN NEW YORK, GIANTS, FEW
MORE MINUTES LEFT WITH HIM
HERE ON THE RICH EYES AND
SHOW. THERE WAS A
AN ARTICLE THAT WAS WRITTEN.
I THINK A FEW MONTHS AGO
TALKING ABOUT
THE ENTIRE STAFF AND
MEMBERS OF THE BUFFALO BILLS
ABOUT MAKING EVERYBODY SIT
DOWN. IF THEY HAD BEEN LET GO
SOMEWHERE OR FIRED SOMEWHERE
AND
THE ONLY PERSON OR CUT OR
RELEASED THE ONLY PERSON LEFT
STANDING IN THE ROOM WAS JOSH
ALLEN AND THEN YOU ASK THEM
WHAT DID YOU ASK HIM AGAIN
AFTER HE WAS LEFT STANDING,
HOW MANY SCHOLARSHIP OFFERS HE
HAD? YOU KNOW, WE WERE THE
ONLY
TEAM
LAST YEAR, IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
OR ONE, THE ONLY TEAMS
THAT HAD NO
FIRST-ROUND DRAFT PICKS ON
OFFENSE, OTHER THAN THE
QUARTERBACK,
NOT AT THE RECEIVER SPOT. ,
AND LOOK THERE'S EXPECTATIONS
EVERY YEAR. CERTAINLY WE HAD
THEM FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR,
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER WHERE YOU COME FROM
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SELECTED IN THE FIRST ROUND,
OR YOU HAVEN'T BEEN FIRED,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S
SOMETIMES THERE'S THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF OBSTACLES THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF YOU. AND I THINK ALL
THE GUYS IN THAT ROOM.
ADVERSITY ALONG THE WAY AND
HOW YOU DEAL WITH THOSE THINGS
MAKES YOU BETTER.
YOU CAN LET IT EAT YOU UP AND
WORRY ABOUT IT AND LET IT
AFFECT YOU,
OR YOU CAN, YOU KNOW,
GRAB HOLD OF IT AND SAY, YEAH,
I'VE BEEN THROUGH SOME ADVERSE
TIMES, I'VE HAD TIMES WHERE
I HAVEN'T BEEN IN MY BEST
OR I WASN'T PICKED OR,
YOU KNOW, I WAS TRADED
A COACH AND LEARN FROM THOSE
EXPERIENCES
AND HIT THEM HEAD ON. AND
AGAIN, WHEN YOU ONLY HAVE ONE
PERSON IN THE ROOM
STANDING,
THAT WASN'T FIRED OR HADN'T
BEEN CUT OR WASN'T PICKED IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
AND THAT PERSON YOU KNOW
WASN'T HIGHLY RECRUITED, YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT HIS STATS
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND HAD TO GO
TO A JUCO AND THEN HAD TO GO
TO WYOMING. THAT WAS THE ONLY
SPOTTY GOOD GOOD. AND THEN
THERE WAS, YOU KNOW, ALL THIS
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PICKED. THERE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN PICKED
HER IS INACCURATE, OR HE'S
THIS,
WHERE YOU COME FROM THAT YOU
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF FUEL
AND IN TERMS OF REMEMBER WHERE
YOU COME FROM, IS THAT WHY YOU
I SAW THAT YOU JUST A TRUE
THAT YOU DRIVE FROM BUFFALO
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO NEW
JERSEY. YEAH.
IT'S NOT A BAD
WHEN YOU GET A NOVEL, I'VE
LEARNED AND GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THIS, WHICH IS A
DREAM OF MINE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PHONE CALLS,
YOU GOT TO RETURN
AND I'VE TRIED TO RETURN, YOU
KNOW, EVERY TEXT, EVERY PHONE
CALL THAT I'VE GOTTEN JUST
BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN IN THAT SITUATION
BEFORE WHERE YOU'RE EITHER
LOOKING FOR A JOB OR YOU'RE
TRYING TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF
TO SOMEBODY. AND I JUST THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE A GOOD
PERSON AND
THERE'S A LOT OF PHONE CALLS
MADE DURING THAT, YOU KNOW,
FIVE AND A HALF, OR SIX HOUR
DRIVE. WHATEVER
WAS A LITTLE BIT LONGER
DO YOU DO? I MEAN,
YOU'RE A PODCAST LISTENER.
AND I THINK THE ENTIRE RIDE
NO, THEY'VE GOT THROUGH A
BIGGIE SONG ON THERE ONCE.
YEAH, OKAY. OKAY,
VERY GOOD,
HYPNOTIZED. OKAY, VERY GOOD.
ALRIGHT. COACH. WE LIKE IT. I
LIKE IT. EVERYBODY HERE. LIKES
IT.
SO,
AND SO, WHO DID YOU CALL? I
MEAN, WHO FROM YOUR LIFE
LIFE? THAT YOU'D BE WILLING?
SHARE ONCE YOU FINALLY DID GET
THIS JOB. I MEAN OUTSIDE OF
YOUR FAMILY.
WHO WOULD YOU CALL? YEAH.
WELL, YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T HAVE
I LOST MY GRANDPARENTS THIS
YEAR WHICH WERE INSTRUMENTAL.
IN MY UPBRINGING,
YOU KNOW, DIDN'T HAVE A FATHER
HAD A TEENAGE MOTHER. WHEN I
WAS BORN IN FORTUNATELY. THEY
BROUGHT US INTO THE HOUSE AND
THEY PASSED AWAY,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF BACK THE
BACK HERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
SEASON,
NOT NECESSARILY RIGHT AT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF SORRY.
THERE'S SOME
IT'S ALL RIGHT. THAT'S GOING
ON HERE. NO WORRIES.
YEAH, SO, I DON'T
KNOW. I CALLED MY MOM AND TALK
TO HER FOR A LITTLE WHILE AND
OBVIOUSLY TALK TO MY WIFE BUT
MADE TO, YOU KNOW, CALLS WERE
SCOUTS. AND PEOPLE JUST
REACHING OUT SAYING
YOU KNOW, JUST TRY TO HIT
THOSE GUYS BACK. ALL RIGHT,
LAST ONE FOR YOU COACH. NOW,
THAT YOU ARE A HEAD COACH
IN THE NFL AND, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFLUENCE THAT COMES WITH
THAT CERTAINLY
WHEN ONE OF THE GENTLEMEN,
WRITING YOUR CHECKS IS
SOME
WHO'S SO INTO ROLE IN THE NFL
AND IT'S SO DEEP INVOLVED IN
THE NFL. HIS FATHER'S NICKNAME
IS ON THE FOOTBALL AND HE'S
COMPETITION COMMITTEE WORLD.
WOULD YOU TELL JOHN MAYER?
I THINK THERE SHOULD BE
CHANGES TO THE OVERTIME RULES
BASED ON THE WAY YOUR TENURE
IN BUFFALO AND AND BRIAN
TABLE. WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THOSE GUYS FIGURE IT OUT.
YEAH. THAT'S WHAT DO YOU
THINK, OBVIOUSLY,
TO HAVE ANOTHER K OF THAT LOVE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE YOU'RE ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF
IT, BUT
YOU JUST FINISH YOUR JOB TO
TRY, NOT TO GET IT INTO
OVERTIME. BUT YOU KNOW, I'LL
LET THOSE GUYS TALK ABOUT
THAT. SO YOU HAVE NO OPINION
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER OR
YOU DO, OR YOU HAVE AN OPINION
ABOUT KEEP THAT ONE OF MYSELF
SORRY, TIES IT.
ALL RIGHT, SO I'LL JUST HAVE
TO GET YOUR NUMBER AND CALL
YOU ON YOUR NEXT EIGHT
HOUR ROAD TRIP. I'LL SEE YOU
AT THE COMBINE AFTER YOU RUN
YOU COULD FIT ME IN. I'LL I .
HOPE SO, I WOULD LOVE TO.
I'D LOVE TO MEET YOU EVER
HEARD. AND WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO RUN THIS YEAR?
WELL,
LOOKING
WHAT WE LOOKING AT, MY BRIAN
ASKED HIM IF HE STARTED
TRAINING IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO I'M NOT GOING
TO THROW WHAT HE STONES
ARE. GLAD
I'M NOT I LIVE IN A GLASS
HOUSE.
STATEMENT IS I'M NOT GOING TO
GET INTO THAT. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT.
THERE IS TRAINING. IS IT? SO
IT'S MUCH BETTER THAN MINE.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT. WELL,
HERE'S THE DEAL. LET'S JUST
SAY THE OTHER MICHIGAN, MAN
THAT YOU MAY HAVE COME ACROSS
IN BRADY'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
WELL, CONDITIONED TO DO AN
ADVANCED AGE THAN I AM. BUT
I GET ON THAT TV 12. I KNOW
I THINK,
THAT'S NOT A BAD IDEA.
SO MY BEST IS
594. I'M HOPING TO BEAT THAT
THIS YEAR.
I'LL BET YOU UNDER. ALL RIGHT,
I APPRECIATE THAT. ALL I
JUST WANT TO DO IS JUST RAISE
AS MUCH MONEY FOR ST. JUDE.
BUT YEAH, THAT'S AWESOME,
YOU KNOW? ALL ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, CHARITY AND MAKING
SURE THAT
THAT THE RIGHT STUFF IS TAKEN
CARE OF. THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY YOU'RE IN THE
POSITION WHERE YOU ARE AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME COACH. I
REALLY DO. YEAH. SAME HERE
GUYS. I APPRECIATE YOU HAVING
ME ON AND LET'S
DO HAVE A GREAT DAY. LET'S DO
THIS MORE
BIGGIE SONG IS THOUGH.
OKAY, YOU WANT TO DO
THAT? WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
BIGGIE SONG?
YEAH, BUT SIGHS. OKAY. I GOT A
LOT OF THEM.
LOT OF THEM ON. I GOT A
ON HIM,
MAYBE I
SHOULD JUST KICK IN THE DOOR
TO HYPE UP YOUR TEAM A LITTLE
BIT, KICKING THE DOOR, KICKING
THE DOOR YET. KICKING THE
DOOR. HE'S GOOD, YOU KNOW,
BIG POPPA CALL THEM. THERE'S A
BUNCH OF THEM. BABY BABY,
BABY. OKAY, VERY GOOD.
GUYS. I THINK YOU SHOULD. I
THINK THE NEXT BREAK ONCE YOU
PLAY A LITTLE BIGGIE,
LET'S JUST DO IT.
PRODUCING PRODUCING, WHICH IS
NOW PUT ME IN A SPOT NOW,
RIGHT?
KNOW WHAT I MEAN. VERY GOOD.
HE'S PUTTING ME ON THE SPOT.
HE ALSO HAS NO
IDEA. HE'S TALKING WITH DIE
HARD.
BOYFRIEND, SO
NOBODY BUT I LIKE THEM RIGHT
OFF THE BAT. SO, YOU KNOW.
THANKS COACH. THANKS. COACH, A
GIRL IS MY DAY WILL EVERYBODY.
THE TOTAL COMPLETE
DELIGHT? MY GOODNESS.
THAT GUY EVER, BUT I'D ABEL'S
LIKE AND BIG E TAKEN UNDER
HIS. MY KIND OF GUY.
LET'S TAKE IT ON TO
US GO. I'D EVEN GO FIVE SUPER
BOWL RINGS. YEAH.
FIVE
YOUR
COWBOY FAN
IN HERE. AND THAT IS THE NEW
AGE. SEE THE GIANTS LOOKS LIKE
THEY'VE,
THEY'VE UPGRADED. THEY
LOOKS LIKE THEY GOT A GOOD GUY
THERE, HUH? I JUST. DO YOU
LOOK. HE'S GOOD WITH A MEDIA
AND HE KNOWS HOW TO HE KNOWS
HOW TO
COACH MAN,
AND HE JUST WON ME OVER WITH
HIS FAVORITE RAPPER. SO I MEAN
ALSO REFERRED TO THE OTHER
SCHOOL AS MICHIGAN. I MEAN MY
GOD, HE'S FROM CANADA.
ALRIGHT, WHICH IS HE'S FROM
CANADA AND HE WENT TO WILLIAM
AND MARY, YOU KNOW, HE'S FIRST
COACHING, JUDGE WILLIAM IN
MARRIED. TWO YEARS WOULD SAY
BEEN AND EAST LANSING AND HE'S
STILL REFERRING TO
MICHIGAN LIKE THAT. YEAH. I
SAW A TWEET TO, BUT WHAT
THAT IS FIRST
YEAR IN NEW ENGLAND.
ONE. HE WAS PAID
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS,
AND HE ASKS BILL,
HOW MANY HOURS A DAY AM I
GOING TO WORK? AND BILL SAID,
WELL HOW MANY HOURS ARE IN THE
HOW ABOUT THAT MAN? ALWAYS
TRUCK DOWN. THIS IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF GUY THAT
NEW YORK IS GOING TO FALL IN
LOVE WITH IF HE
WINS.